madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 21 juillet
la baisse de rémunération du livret à
elle passe de 3 à 2,25 pour cent le
gouvernement décide de baisser la
rémunération de l'épargné populaire pour
tenir compte de l'inflation et relancer
la construction des logements sociaux
aux etats unis la confirmation est venue
du fond de l'océan le corps de john
kennedy junior a été retrouvé au large
de yanis porte
les recherches se poursuivent pour
localiser ceux de sa femme et de sa
belle soeur la bataille de cherbourg n'a
pas eu lieu le pacifique thil a repris
la mer pour le japon avec sa cargaison
de combustible nucléaire
les navires de greenpeace ont été
maintenus à l'écart le tour de france
lance armstrong sort encore renforcée
des pyrénées et contre attaque sur le
plan du dopage
blanchi par l'union cycliste
internationale il met en cause la presse
dans ce journal
richard gringue sera notre invité nous
ferons un premier bilan avec 8 de sa
participation à cette édition 99
et puis nous dirons tout sur l'éclipsé
totale du 11 août équipe du soleil
france 2 a mis en place un dispositif
exceptionnel pour vous la faire vivre le
mieux possible
l'océan a donc décidé de restituer le
corps de jef k junior à sa famille
l'étape l'épave de l'appareil et le
corps de l'héritier ont été retrouvés au
large de nice porte reste encore à
localiser ceux de sa femme et de sa
belle soeur nous retrouvons états unis
parce qu'elle joue c'est bon
il est midi à yanis porte un hélicoptère
des gardes-côtes se pose dans la
propriété des kennedy ted et patrick y
prennent place
ils partent pour le vaisseau mère de la
flotte de secours reconnaître le corps
de john john
dès hier soir grâce à leur sonar les
plongeurs savait qu'il touchait au but
et c'est pour cela que les recherches
n'avaient pas été interrompues pour la
nuit
à 5h30 heure française par douze mètres
de fond un des hommes grenouilles
aperçoit un morceau de fuselage dans le
faisceau de sa lente
puis il découvre un corps qu'ils
reconnaissent immédiatement sans aucune
hésitation disent ses supérieurs la
dépouille de john kennedy junior aurait
été remonté quelques minutes plus tard à
la surface mais il n'y a aucune
confirmation officielle pour l'instant
en revanche aucune trace du reste de
l'appareil et des corps de l'épousé de
la belle soeur de john john même s'ils
ne sont peut-être pas loin
les recherches sont très lentes water
bathing l'eau est à moi de 10° dit cet
officier et même avec les lampes
on y voit pas plus de trois mètres la
maison blanche et la famille kennedy ont
immédiatement été averti pas de réaction
pour l'instant hier soir caroline la
soeur du défunt a quitté sa maison de
long island pour new york
elle souhaiterait prendre en main
l'organisation des cérémonies
alors parce qu'une douce et bonsoir ou
bonjour pour vous c'est en quelque sorte
un soulagement pour la famille on
imagine d'avoir pu récupérer le corps de
john john kennedy
est-ce qu'il est question d'obsèques
nationales d'enterrement dans le
cimetière d'arlington au côté de son
père apparemment il n'y aurait d'abord
aucune cérémonie tant que les trois
accords n'auront pas été retrouvés
apparemment je dis bien les deux
familles bessette et kelly se seraient
entendus dans ce sens mais il n'y a rien
d'officiel pour l'instant deux choses
sont sûres en revanche quelle que soit
leur date les cérémonie aurait lieu à
new york dans la ville que john kennedy
junior et carolyn bessette émettant et
certainement pas à washington ou partout
ailleurs d'autre part selon les souhaits
du défunt ses cendres seront dispersées
en mer
hélas ce n'est pas anecdotique vous
savez que la maison blanche avait donné
son accord pour que john kennedy junior
soit enterré à arlington dans le
cimetière fédéral là où reposent john
kennedy père et de nombreux présidents
américains mais la famille kennedy cette
fois ci a décliné en quelque sorte
l'invitation elle pense que john kennedy
junior n'aurait pas souhaité être
enterré à cet endroit vous savez qu'il
ne voulait pas être si j'ose dire un
kennedy de plus qu'ils ne voulaient pas
embrassés
arrières politiques et toutes les
contraintes que cette vie suppose et en
prenant cette décision la famille pense
qu'elle le laisserait en conformité avec
ce qu'il avait voulu faire de sa vie
merci parce que l'actualité en france et
bien sûr la baisse de rémunération de
l'épargné populaire une décision
difficile pour le gouvernement qui
refusait de l'envisager à la veille des
élections européennes
cette fois c'est décidé dominique
strauss kahn l'a annoncé ce sera -0 75%
pour le livret à qui passe ainsi de 3 2
25%
même chose pour le livret bleu et le
codevi la rémunération du livret
d'épargné populaire pas celle à 4 62 4
75% à 4 % et le plan d'épargne-logement
de 4 à 3,6 pour cent
cette décision est bien sûr accueilli
assez fraîchement par les principaux
concernés 46 millions de personnes
autrement dit huit français sur dix
possèdent un livret a
elle est également critiquée par arlette
laguiller qui se dit scandalisé par la
cgt qui la trouvent injuste et par le
rpr qui estime que le gouvernement a
perdu beaucoup de temps pour une mesure
jugée inévitable dominique strauss-kahn
a aussitôt annoncé qu'il n'y aurait plus
d'autres mesures de ce type les
explications de sébastien guibert et de
yann fronty il y a quatre mois dominique
strauss kahn avait été catégorique pas
question de baisser les taux il fallait
préserver l'épargné populaire
c'était avant les élections européennes
mais aujourd'hui changement de ton les
taux de rémunération selon le ministre
sont trop élevés nous avons donc là une
épargne stérile une épargne stérile ça
veut dire moins d'investissements ça
veut dire moins de croissance et au bout
du compte ça veut dire moins d'emplois
il était donc urgent d'agir
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui décision
délicate
le livret a est le produit d'épargné le
plus populaire 720 milliards de francs
déposés par 46 millions de français
le gouvernement n'a pourtant pas
totalement suivi l'avis des banquiers
qui souhaitaient une baisse du taux plus
forte encore avec selon la cgt un
objectif clair essayer de récupérer une
partie des dépôts qui sont aujourd'hui
sur les livret à a fin de l'ère drainer
vers des produits financiers et au
travers de cette opération d'améliorer
la rentabilité de la banque on est donc
très loin de la préoccupation du
logement social
mais cette mesure vise à aider les hlm
l'argent des livret a est en effet géré
par la caisse des dépôts et
consignations
qui prêtent ensuite cet argent aux
organismes hlm ce taux d'emprunt suit le
taux de rémunération
il baissera donc lui aussi à 3,8 pour
cent ça nous permettrait d'une part
certainement de modérer les loyers comme
on l'a indiqué même de jeu déjà une voix
y ait d'autre part de relancer la
construction locative sociale
cette baisse est donc bienvenu pour les
hlm qui n'ont construit l'an passé que
la moitié des logements prévus en
contrepartie donc on vient de le voir le
gouvernement annonce des mesures pour
relancer le logement social et décide le
gel donc des loyers dans les hlm pour
deux ans il faut dire que 45 mille
logements sociaux seulement été
construits l'an dernier alors que
l'objectif était de 80 milles ce manque
de logements sociaux se fait cruellement
sentir c'est ce que révèle le haut
comité pour le logement des personnes
défavorisées dans son rapport qu'il a
remis hier à jacques chirac actuellement
en france sept cent trente mille
personnes n'ont pas accès à ce que l'on
appelle un logement autonome la majorité
vit dans des hôtels des meublés cent
mille sont hébergés par des proches
45000 dans des abris de fortune et 35
milles dans des centres d'accueil
sans compter le million et demi de
ménages qui ont des difficultés à régler
leur loyer en fin de mois
illustration de ses difficultés au
quotidien avec ce reportage dans la
région parisienne de géraldine d'alban
morenas et didier da
à première vue nous sommes dans un
immeuble cossu du xviiie arrondissement
façades ravalées cage d'escalier
repeinte
mais ces travaux de rénovation se sont
arrêtés sur le palier yahia diakité vit
ici avec sa femme et ses deux enfants
quatre personnes dans 14 mètres carrés
600 francs de loyer
le premier ennemi de yahia c'est
l'humidité il y a deux mois il a refait
le plafond qui s'effondrait mais déjà
les moisissures et apparaissent un peu
partout comme une guerre perdue d'avancé
il est humble avis voici huit enfants
sont nés ici six ont dû repartir au
sénégal faute de place les deux derniers
sont asthmatiques yahia écrit lettre sur
lettre à la mairie de paris pour
déménager
sans sucre est hélas si ce groupe a sans
cesse été la première enfant est né se
demande ce qu une attente qui s'explique
en deux chiffres depuis 12 ans 140 mille
logements à petits loyers ont été
construits plus de deux millions ont été
détruits c'est les communes qui refusent
et qui sort que ben bouhout dans un
refus parce qu'ils veulent pas voir
arriver des gens défavorisés
il en faudrait que l'état puisse d
inciter mais dans le quartier yahia
s'estime presque privilégié il à l'eau
et l'électricité dans le cotentin la
bataille de cherbourg n'a pas eu lieu
les militants greenpeace avait pourtant
mobilisé deux de leurs navires pour
empêcher le pacifique tilde embarquer sa
cargaison de mox ce combustible
nucléaire recyclés à destination du
japon le cargo est bien reparti pour
l'île du soleil levant
un important dispositif de sécurité
avait été mis en place pour l'occasion à
cherbourg le reportage de frédéric dupuy
et dominique bonnet le canot de
greenpeace n'ira pas plus loin à une
petite centaine de mètres du cargo
bloqué par la présence des commandos de
la marine nationale
ce matin vers 10 heures le face-à-face
commence greenpeace et son sirius ce
poste à une encablure du pacifique t-il
objectif manifester contre le chargement
du cargo en provenance de l'ue
gemma de l'eau atteint son but ce type
de nucléaire à base de plutonium
le mox un voyage direction le japon
presque sans risque selon la cogema mais
pas de danger particulier ce sont les
mêmes types de transport que les
transports d'en bas des transports de
combustibles usés qui sont tout à fait
régulier entre le japon et la france en
particulier
pourtant les militants de greenpeace
craignent l'accident en mer ou le
piratage d'un produit qu'il qualifie de
dangereux est sorti quand on voit le
déploiement de forces qui a dans ce port
autour de ce bateau maintenant une
vedette en face de moi de deux bâtiments
militaires derrière plus les zodiac du
raid
je pense que ça signifie quand même le
le caractère très sensible de ce
matériel matériel
encore une fois qui composait de
plutonium plutonium dont on fait les
bombes atomiques
mais un tel déploiement de sécurité et
motivée en partie par la simple présence
de greenpeace dans le port de cherbourg
alors toute la journée militants et
militaires s'observe on joue à la guerre
des mots car l'organisation pacifique
sous le coup d'une injonction de justice
n'a plus le droit d'approcher de trop
près le cargo la gendarmerie maritime
demande alors à greenpeace de quitter
les lieux
je ne comprends pas l'article 2 de votre
décision qui nous ordonne de quitter les
eaux territoriales
en fin d'après-midi les militants de
greenpeace 1 800 regarde partir le cargo
et son chargement pour un périple de 20
mille kilomètres et un itinéraire donné
secret et dans la drôme à solers yeux ce
sont cent mille fûts de déchets
radioactifs essentiellement de la
fluorine qui sont stockés dans une
décharge tout à fait ordinaire les fûts
s'accumulent tacite depuis 22 ans sans
protection particulière et même s'ils
sont classés tf a c'est à dire très
faiblement radioactifs
le préfet de la drôme vient d'ordonner
une étude de sol jacques cardoze et
michel commun que contiennent réellement
ces fûts voilà une question à laquelle
personne est actuellement en mesure de
répondre avec exactitude
depuis le 5 novembre 75 la préfecture de
la drôme autorise cette décharge à
stocker des déchets radioactifs en tout
genre y at il du pyralène comme certains
écologistes le prétendent
la préfecture dément reste la présence
certaine de deux types d'uranium naturel
et retraités
or c'est cela qui pourrait poser
problème cette décharge est illégal à
deux niveaux elle est illégale sur le
fait qu'ils aient de l'uranium retraité
à l'intérieur de cette fluorine et
depuis 97
l'arrêté préfectoral interdit le fait de
mettre la floride avec de l'uranium
retraité et deuxièmement il y a des
déchets toxiques chimiques y sont
interdits dans ce type de décharge donc
il faut absolument fermer cette décharge
mais pour la préfecture pas question
d'interdire le stockage à solers yeux ni
même d'aller plus loin que l'arrêté
préfectoral
il n'y avait pas lieu qui soit plus
restrictif puisque on disait qu'à partir
de ce moment là il fallait se limiter à
certains types de fluorine au village il
y a ceux qui en vivent
et ceux qui le dénoncent le maire de la
commune ne se sent pas concernés par
d'éventuels risques sanitaires
les organismes d'état nous rende corps
au niveau de la commune une fois par an
du contenu de la décharge est des
analyses qui ont été faites
aujourd'hui rien rien ne nous pousse au
niveau de la municipalité à intervenir
sur les résultats neil au prix renie la
drire les deux organismes concernés
n'ont en effet relevé d'anomalie des
relevés sont effectués tous les six mois
dans la nappe phréatique et l'ère des
charges qui vendent dans le talus et en
face à la carrière est bien là alors ça
chante ça marche pas alors je suis bien
tranquille oreilles en 22 ans aucune
étude d'impact sérieuses n'a été
réalisée c'est ce que réclame en
priorité les défenseurs de la nature
pour qu'enfin on sache si oui ou non un
risque de contamination existe après la
découverte de deux cadavres enterrés
près d'une auberge dans l'aveyron le
propriétaire alfredo stranieri a été mis
en examen pour enlèvement séquestration
et assassinat
c'est également près d'une de ses
propriétés une ancienne discothèque que
deux autres corps ont été découverts
il s'agirait là aussi des anciens
propriétaires qui lui avait vendu
c'était cet établissement
c'est grâce au témoignage du père d'une
des deux victimes supposées nathalie
girard que les enquêteurs ont pu
retrouver ces corps stéphane breitner et
delphine detry le rencontrer
pour la deuxième journée consécutive
alfredo stranieri a été ramené à
l'auberge de bez de naussac
là où hier les gendarmes ont découvert
deux cadavres enterrés dans le jardin
entendu ce soir dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction de rodez
alfredo stranieri doit être mise en
examen pour assassinat
stranieri un homme que connaît bien
claude girard sa fille et son compagnon
ont disparu après avoir cédé leur
discothèque de viry châtillon à ce même
stranieri c'était en novembre 90 est
sans nouvelles de sa fille claude girard
décide de rencontrer le nouveau
propriétaire des lieux
la première fois que j'ai vu ce trait
nier que j'ai pris contact avec lui
ces deuxièmes du deuxième quinzaine de
décembre c'est à peu près dans ces eaux
là je ne comprends pas pourquoi ma fille
qui souhaitait passer noël avec nous
avec lui tout d'un coup il n'y plus rien
et là il me dit ben on écoutait son père
qui est leur valise pendant deux ans il
a cru à la version d'alfredo stranieri
trois jours après la découverte macabre
claude girard a du mal à cacher sa
colère il va me distiller des
informations les plus plausibles mais
les plus mensongère on a revu votre
fille à châtelet-les-halles votre fille
est enceinte est enceinte de deux mois
il me dira plus tard à la eu un petit
garçon début août
et ça colle il va me dire sa fin
décembre
fin août vous faites le calcul ça colle
aujourd'hui ce père ne réalise toujours
pas qu'il ne reverra jamais sa fille je
me ferais refusent inconsciemment à
admettre une évidence qui se fait jour
oui savez c'est pas du jour au lendemain
qu'on va dire on peut dire c'est tout
ceci est tellement normal que mon enfant
est mort
claude girard s'en remet désormais à la
justice son seul espoir pour trouver une
explication à la mort probable de sa
fille et dans le nord c'est une autre
affaire qui secoue la région de lille un
homme de 30 ans déjà arrêté et écroué
pour le viol d'une fillette en janvier
dernier vient de reconnaître les viols
et les meurtres de trois autres petites
filles qu'il n'avait jamais été élucidé
marianne masse et dominique maes pour
les enquêteurs c'est lé pilote d'une
série d'affaires non résolues qui auront
vu se succéder plusieurs générations
administratif de policiers denis vaccin
a tout avoué du premier meurtre commis
en 85 alors qu'il n'avait que 16 ans
jusqu'au viol de wendy 7 ans en janvier
dernier le petit wendy nous l'a reconnu
sur une photo graphic donc l'intéressé
était été interpellés je peux dire qu
assez rapidement les enquêteurs se sont
aperçus qu'il pouvait posséder un profil
criminogènes intéressant intéressante
policièrement parlant et 7
cette remarque s'est avéré
s'est avéré positif puisque les analyses
adn ont montré que nous avions raison
les analyses qui avait été réalisée
suite au meurtre et au viol de nadja en
1992 et qui ont permis de confondre le
meurtrier
nadja en 92 mais aussi nathalie en 85 et
cathy en 90 trois meurtres de fillettes
commis dans le même secteur les
quartiers sud de l'île et selon le même
mode opératoire
tony vaccin a longuement été entendu par
le juge et mis en examen pour enlèvement
de mineur de moins de 15 ans suivi de
viol est mort avec arme
il aurait aussi avoué des attouchements
sur d'autres fillettes l'homme prétexte
une absence de souvenirs et dit avoir
été victime de sévices sexuels dans sa
jeunesse
aujourd'hui les enquêteurs fouillent le
passé de cet ancien pompiste de 30 ans
qui a été placé à l'isolément en prison
à l'étranger maintenant au kosovo la
kfor or est officiellement identifié 200
sites de charniers éventuelle mais les
autorités de la force de paix aussi bien
que les enquêteurs du tribunal pénal
international se montre très prudent à
chaque fois les enquêtes sont délicates
et plus personne maintenant ne se
hasarde à avancer de chiffres sur
l'étendue des exactions commises par les
serbes au kosovo comme le montre ce
reportage d'agnès vahramian et de
nathalie gallet dans la région de pécs
ce sont ces montagnes que les équipes du
tribunal pénal international sillonne
depuis quinze jours dans la région de
pécs on leur a signalé 31 lieux
contenant des corps ou des restes
humains
ces policiers sont suédois spécialiste
des affaires criminelles
l'enquêteur lui et sri lankais dans ce
village ce vieil albanais n'est pas un
témoin direct
mais ils expliquent qu'ils ont trouvé en
dix endroits des bouts de squelette
regardez dit-il il y a aussi les clés
une monde
puis il indique l'impact d'une balle
selon lui des milliers de personnes
s'étaient rassemblées ici des villages
voisins
les serbes alors arrivé aurait procédé à
des exécutions
la tâche est compliquée pour les
policiers pas de corps donc pas de topsy
pas de décompte exact des victimes et
des témoignages rapportés flou on parle
aux gens à travers un interprète il
s'est donc difficile de s'expliquer et
d'obtenir des réponses précises
puis les enquêteurs s'intéressent à
l'histoire du village
si ruines lui racontent les habitants
date de l'été dernier lors des premiers
combats entre lou checa dont voici le
responsable local et l'armée yougoslave
ce combattant explique que les
villageois ont apporté leur soutien la
guérilla albanaise mais qu'ils étaient
sans armes
les indications précieuses pour les
enquêteurs qui subodore des représailles
serbes contre les civils autant dire des
crimes de guerre au kosovo le thé pays
préfèrent parler de sites d' enquête
plutôt que de charniers ces enquêteurs
ne sont pas encore venus ici
nous sommes à stoke dans l'ouest comme
partout kosovo ce sont les militaires de
l'alliance qui ont découvert ces tombes
97 stèle portant tout une même date le
26 mai et les mêmes lettres kpd pour la
prison dit stocks pour les albanais les
serbes ont assassiné les détenus mais il
y plus que plausible que l'on est
enterré ici les victimes du bombardement
de l'otan sur la prison d'istok le 21
mai dernier le terme de charniers
recouvre en fait autant de réalités
différentes que d'incertitudes souvent
ce sont des corps éparpillés sans
identité des morts sans témoin sinon
plusieurs années que finira le travail
du tribunal pénal international et l'on
saura peut-être alors combien de
victimes a fait ce conflit en turquie le
premier ministre a annoncé
triomphalement la capture quelque part
en europe du bras droit d'abdullah
ocalan le leader kurde du pkk condamne à
mort il ya quelques semaines
cette capture aurait eu lieu en moldavie
ce que démentent les autorités moldaves
et puis en espagne un nouveau pas vient
en outre d'être vers la paix vient en
outre d'être franchie avec la libération
de l'ancienne direction du parti
indépendantiste basque
herri batasuna mais 23 militants avait
été incarcéré en septembre 97 et
condamné à sept ans de prison pour avoir
diffusé une cassette vidéo de letea
pendant leur campagne électorale
le tribunal suprême a estimé qu'il ne
s'agissait pas là d'un des lions jacques
chirac entame ce soir une tournée de
cinq jours en afrique il doit visiter
successivement la guinée le togo le
nigeria et le cameroun pour y promouvoir
selon l'elysée dans l'argent rapidement
de la démocratie dans ces quatre pays en
guinée où il est arrivé tout à l'heure
et chirac et donc l'hôte du président
lansana conté après 26 ans d'une
dictature socialiste son pays s'est
rallié à l'économie libérale
mais la question des droits de l'homme
ne sera bien sûr au menu de cette
première visite africaine sur place à
conakry
eric monier et jean cordier
cependant jacques chirac et le fonds de
commerce les petits vendeurs dans un
pays francophone où la visite du
président français n'a pourtant pas la
même résonance key depuis le non
historique à de gaulle en 1958 la guinée
a appris à vivre sans la france mais les
choses changent entre les deux pays
devenu premier fournisseur et deuxième
client de conakry paris accompagne le
lent décollage économique de 7 mais
potentiellement si riche mais encore
handicapé par les 25 ans de règne
catastrophique que c'est beaucoup
vertueuse dans l'humanitaire la guinée
déçoit en revanche sur les droits de
l'homme la question qui fâche ici
concerne alpha condé l'un des opposants
battu à l'élection partielle emprisonnés
pour des motifs encore floues avant même
l'arrivée du président français le
gouvernement tentait d'éviter tout débat
ce matin d'un problème dîner s'agissant
d'un guinéen qui a renoncé à toutes ces
nationalités pour être candidat 1998 à
la présidence guinéenne laisser légumes
érigée en guinée alpha condé devrait
être jugé en septembre un procès
politique
selon l'un de ses avocats je sais que
monsieur alpha condé a été l'adversaire
politique très coriace ici à une
possibilité éventuellement d'arrêter cet
adversaire politique
pourquoi pas à son homologue guinéen
jacques chirac parlera économie
stabilité régionale mais on guette le
président français sur ce dossier des
droits de l'homme ici à conakry mais
aussi dès demain au togo assurément le
moment fort de ce voyage estival en
afrique
un petit mot sur l'actualité politique
en france elle est marqué ce soir par le
dîner organisé à matignon par lionel
jospin quelques semaines seulement après
les élections européennes
il reçoit tous les chefs de file de la
gauche plurielle notamment les verts qui
réclament le savez un réquilibrage à
leur profit au sein du gouvernement on
parlera sans doute aussi de l'éventuel
remplacement de bernard kouchner partie
au kosovo le tour de france est la
deuxième et dernière étape des pyrénées
une étape remportée par l'espagnol david
etxebarria qui signe là son deuxième
succès dans le tour mais le principal
vainqueur de ces deux journées à haut
risque c'est bien sûr
lance armstrong le maillot jaune qui en
sort encore renforcé florent gautreau et
philippe deslandes
le grimpeur est un être à part qui se
révèle et s'élève quand tous les
éléments extérieurs voudrait l'anéantir
élites ont cov etxebarria sont fait de
ce bois là le soulor ses spectateurs
hurlant et son brouillard aveuglant ne
les impressionne guerre derrière les
trois échappés amstrong escardines et du
le accélère les trois premiers du
classement général ont décidé de mettre
fin à une échappée qui dure depuis le
tourmalet virons pluie n'a pas pu suivre
les patrons du tour tout un symbole la
course est nerveuse et le public
volontiers moqueur rinero n'a pas
apprécié la réflexion d'un spectateur
il fonce sur lui hésite même à s'arrêter
l'homme en bleu lui aurait crié ça
marche moins bien sans epo
cette suspicion le peloton ne la
supporte plus surtout les français qui
sont en pointe en matière de lutte
contre le dopage
pendant ce temps là les trois hommes de
tête ont intelligemment relâcher leur
effort anticipant le retour du groupe du
maillot jaune
etxebarria à droite en noir a conservé
suffisamment de fraîcheur pour
s'échapper à nouveau dans les derniers
hectomètres avec cinq autres coureurs
l'espagnol vainqueur à saint flour
vendredi en solitaire s'impose cette
fois au sprint
de son côté armstrong terminant 11e son
maillot jaune n'a jamais été menacé le
tour est presque gagnée mais en seconde
semaine un autre combat un combat contre
les rumeurs de dopage ce soir
l'américain a expliqué pourquoi on avait
trouvée dans ses urines des traces de
corticoïdes
j'ai commis l'erreur d'utiliser une
pommade pour traiter une irritation à la
seule ce produit a laissé apparaître au
contrôle des traces infimes de
corticoïdes
le journal le monde pense que c'est une
affaire de dopage pour moi en réalité
c'est tout simplement d'affaires de
pommade
ainsi va le tour 99 entre suspicion et
dénégations
en attendant on ne voit pas ce qui peut
empêcher amstrong de remporter le 96e
tour de france avec lyon duplex de pau
richard virenque bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir j'imagine vous êtes un
peu fatigué donc on vous attendait dans
l'est on vous attendait dans les
pyrénées vous avez fait une belle étape
hier et aujourd'hui ça l'est vraiment
trop vite là c'était pas possible de
suivre en tout cas de montée sur un
podium
je crois qu en arrivant quatre jours
avant le départ elle dit que quatre
jours avant le départ du tour de france
j'allais faire un tour de france est
difficile de penser un podium même une
victoire finale mais je crois que ce que
j'ai fait dans ce tour au jour
d'aujourd'hui laisse me laisse rêveur
pour les autres années quoi donc j'ai eu
la moins bonne des préparations et
aujourd'hui je suis 5e du général
maillot à pois donc
j'ai été dans avec les meilleurs dans
les grands moments alors justement vous
faites allusion
vous faites allusion à votre préparation
votre votre arrivée sur le tour n'était
pas vraiment souhaité un par jean marie
leblanc
vous avez l'impression que lui cia eu
raison de vous imposer dans ce tour ben
j'ai pu prouver
sportivement ce que je venais donc
je crois que après le tour d'italie que
j'ai fait
ça aurait été bien que je sache que
j'aille au tour mais bon c'est pas été
le cas donc j'ai pensé plus aux vacances
qu'à autre chose
et quand on vous dit trois ou quatre
jours avant le tour de france est bâti
va je suis passé des sacrifices que
j'aurais dû faire entraînement
nourriture tout ce qui s'ensuit donc je
peux vous dire que
être là aujourd'hui à ma place
c'est pas mal mais pour l'image du tour
pour la lutte contre le dopage c'était
une bonne chose que vous soyez là cette
année
je pense que je me suis soumis à tous
les contrôles qui qui a pu être il ya
aucun problème et j'ai remporté pour la
cinquième fois le meilleur point donc
gelé remporté dans le passé je leur
apporte maintenant je suis dans le top
au classement général donc qu'est-ce
qu'on veut plus non en a beaucoup on a
beaucoup parlé de ce tour de france on a
dit que ça allait peut être être celui
du renouveau matin il y en a ce soir
enfin aujourd'hui qui disent que ça n'a
pas été le cas vous allez passion clé
les choses ont changé que l'ambiance a
changé que sur le tour que les les
coureurs sont plus claires si je puis
dire
j'ai l'impression que amstrong réaliser
un exploit
il ressort d'une maladie
istres est très difficile à guérir et il
a combattu sa maladie après il revient
au premier plan sportivement on essaye
entrants de l'ue cherchait encore des
noix je crois qu'il faudrait plus tirer
un grand coup de chapeau à ce courage
que la presse pardon vous pensez que la
pressant en fait trop qu'on parle trop
du dopage comme le comme le dit lance
amstrong justement aujourd'hui
ouais je pense qu'il ya une presse qui
est spécialisé pour moi agacer ou pour
traiter les des choses qui sont pas
normales à traiter quoi mais sinon je
repose ma question tout à l'heure sur le
tour vous avez l'impression que les
choses ont changé que l'ambiance a
changé que les choses sont peut-être
plus dur maintenant pour les coureurs
parce que parce que certains quand même
on le sait se doper ben pour ma part je
trouvais que le tour il y avait une très
bonne ambiance qu'il y avait beaucoup de
public
j'ai ressenti le tour comme dans les
années 98 97 96 avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé au coup de
de gens sur les routes j'ai pas ressenti
un tour abattu ou c'était la tristesse
partout dans le village départ
tout se passait bien moins pour ma part
j'ai vécu un beau tour de france est un
peu dur
parce que j'ai été beaucoup sollicités
mais
sinon le renouveau ce qu'on a vu dans
l'est dans le passé dans le général mais
salue aujourd'hui ou voilà ce que
visiblement vous ne regretterez pas
d'être venu et vous en avez pensé vous
fait le fait la démonstration merci
beaucoup à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir et puis bien sûr on
vous suit dans l'est dans les étapes
suivantes avec notamment le contre la
montre et on vous verra l'arrivée à
paris merci beaucoup et bonsoir les
clips bonsoir l'équipe ce total ce sera
le 11 août la dernière du millénaire en
france la prochaine aura lieu en 2081 la
précédente avait eu lieu en 1961
inutile de dire qu'il ne s'agit pas de
la rate et celle là elle sera visible
sur une bande d'une centaine de
kilomètres de large qui va de cherbourg
à l'alsace en passant juste au dessus de
paris
pour vous la faire vivre complètement
france 2 a mis en place un dispositif
exceptionnel avec comme chaque année la
nuit des étoiles le 10 au soir animé par
claude sérillon et puis une émission
spéciale de 11h30 à 13h le 11 août
explications et présentation de ce
dispositif avec patrice pollet et marcel
martin marché sur la france peut sembler
impossible et pourtant on peut le faire
au carrousel du louvre
cette carte géante de 30 mètres de long
représente le trajet de l'éclipsé du 11
août de cherbourg à strasbourg les
hameaux les villages les champs rien ne
manque
le long du parcours on peut apprendre à
quelle heure arrivera les clips ce et sa
durée voyez qui si on arrive à une
éclipse totale de lune minutes 43
secondes
au niveau 2
de clermont dans l'oise par exemple et
si on continue toujours sur le méridien
de paris on arrive ici en place sur la
ligne de centralité donc c'est vraiment
la ligne optimum on est à breteuil et là
on a une durée d'éclipsé totale de 2
minutes 14 secondes
une éclipse c'est beau le 11 août
d'ouest en est pour traverser la france
elle mettra 15 minutes un magnifique
spectacle en perspective
à condition bien sûr que la météo soit
bonne la déception
un astronome au monde avec lips sait si
le ciel est couvert et alors pour éviter
ça j'ai essayé de mettre en place un
système de faire voler un avion à
réaction à une altitude de 10 km au
dessus des nuages accrochés au dessus
d'un missile de combat voici la caméra
qui va suivre le soleil
c'est un vrai missile mais sans explosif
dont le système gyroscopique va être
verrouillé sur l'astre le résultat une
visée bien dans laxe est une image qui
sera retransmise en direct sur france 2
pendant presque toute la durée de
l'éclipsé
le 11 août le soleil a rendez vous avec
la lune
nous serons là pour vous faire vivre cet
événement
et avec nous en direct du carrousel du
louvre jean-françois munster bonsoir
vous êtes directeur de l'institut des
sciences de l'univers au cnrs et donc
avec vous france 2 s'est associé pour
retransmettre ses vêtements cet
événement et ne pas dire trop de bêtises
alors qu'est-ce que ça d'exceptionnel
une éclipse au in éclipsé par la veine
est un événement rare à la surface de la
terre mais c'est un événement rare au
dessus de la france comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure
d'autre part c'est un événement
magnifique magique
non seulement parce que le ciel change
le soleil est complètement masqué par la
lune quand il s'agit d'une éclipse
totale mais également parce que vous
pouvez voir les étoiles
les animaux se taisent au moment où le
soleil revient le ciel se lève sur tous
horizons 360 degrés autour de vous donc
c'est un événement à ne pas manquer qui
est magique qu'il faut voir et dans
l'histoire ça souvent suscité des peurs
1 et les des croyances alors on voit
derrière vous cette espèce de 4 cette
carte sur laquelle on peut se promener
on peut repérer en fait dessus les
endroits où on pourra vraiment bien
observé le l'équipe c'est ça le mode
d'emploi
oui c'est le mode d'emploi l'institut
géographique national installé cette
carte dans le hall du carrousel du
louvre et chacun peut se promener sur la
carte choisir le lieu l'éminence où il
veut se placer pour bien voir ce qui se
passe c'est quoi c'est quoi les les que
les conditions d'une bonne observation
faut pas être gênés par les lumières de
la ville afin de lumière ne sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour être en
hauteur faut être l'équipe sera à 12h15
mais si on veut bien voir ce qui se
passe je préconiserais volontiers dans
un endroit dégagé sur une éminence et en
parallèle de mètres sont signés de
magnétoscope pour regarder les images
qui seront prises depuis l'avion et par
les autres caméras de télévision et il
faut pas je crois faut faire attention
un faux-pas four aux yeux ccc c'est
curieux à dire mais une éclipse se
savait blues oui c'est une contrainte
est essentielle et d'ailleurs il y aura
pas mal de communication sur ce sujet il
même des lunettes de soleil ne suffisent
pas même des verres fumés ou des
il ya positives qui ont été mal prise ne
suffisent pas il faut faire très
attention il faut prendre des verts de
millar ou des masques de soudeurs ou
superposer plusieurs lunettes
c'est une contrainte très forte il faut
la respecter merci beaucoup et puis vous
avez vous des idées du lyonnais ce qu'on
pourra trouver dans les pharmacies je
crois qu'ils soient en vente pour un
prix d'environ 5 francs merci oui vous
pouvez trouver aussi plein de
renseignements dans ce livre qui
habitait l'institut mécanique céleste
sur les éclipses et en particulier sur
celle là comment faire une photo comment
regarder l'éclipsé avec un magnétoscope
vous trouverez tous les renseignements
dans ce petit ouvrage qui s'appelle les
éclipse du soleil
merci beaucoup en tout cas merci
beaucoup jean-françois master et puis on
suivra donc cette éclipse sur sur france
2 c'est presque aussi difficile à
observer qu'une éclipse presque aussi
éblouissant aussi la haute couture
continue ses défilés avec ce soir yves
saint laurent et thierry mugler
reportage de nicole candu langlois et de
bernard connor faut rationner déterminé
régénérer c'est un yves saint-laurent
prêt à relever tous les défis qui est
venu saluer avec sa mariée laetitia
casta un feu d'artifice de créativité de
joie de vivre avec ses blues brodé à la
roumaine sur jupe de velours perfection
détail drapés des robes de satin ou de
jersey au décolleté généreux
abondance de fourrure du renard surtout
pour réchauffer une robe stricte
n'éblouit sentent collection comme si le
maître avait voulu se surpasser pour
entrer dans le millénaire
plus claire et dans cette robe altière
monumentale et désinvolte en même temps
le style s'impose dans un mouvement de
spirale une vestale vêtue d'une robe
tosh suggère la nudité des velours noir
nous le cor dessine des décolletés
périlleux et astucieux accompagné de
longs gants de gildas deux manches
bourgogne d'une blouse évanescente la
taille et parfois marquées à outrance
corsetée avec humour ou ganser d'or en
lamelles qu'allah aquatique méduses de
balle en or dans un gouffre et dégradé
de pastels pour la première fois thierry
mugler propose une véritable robe de
mariée en tulle blanc drapé qui illustre
sa démarche d'esthétique de
sophistication et de beauté intemporelle
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
en rappelle les principaux titres à la
baisse de rémunération du livret a elle
passe de 3 à 2 25 % le gouvernement
décide ainsi de baisser la rémunération
de l'épargné populaire pour tenir compte
de l'inflation et relancer la
construction des logements sociaux
et puis aux etats unis la confirmation
est venue du fond des océans le corps de
john kennedy junior a été retrouvé au
large de yanis porte les recherches
poursuit maintenant pour localiser ceux
de sa femme et de sa belle soeur dans un
instant la météo ce sera isabelle
martinet à zéro heure quinze journal de
la nuit remettait vers 13 heures demain
vous retrouverez carole gaessler et
rachid arhab et moi j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver à 20h bonne soirée sur
france 2
oh